4K slogan with a gifted
five tier one memberships hold up hold
up hold up
I don't know why the notification didn't
pop but
might just take it a second and then I
think two games to play renewed their
membership I'm not sure if they were a
gifted no I think they renewed then we
had lowercase Logan gifted out five
tier one memberships Logan thank you so
much dude
and then a yo Rob has renewed their tier
one membership so let's see oh yeah so
we got two renewals AO Rob
became a channel member
and then we also had two games to play
renewing their Channel membership for
three months so then lowercase Logan
gifted out five memberships we got Neil
Tom okay wait hey yo Rob got one of the
gifteds
see dude like I take a week off and now
stream elements is Jake vibes
I can't this this webcam is insane man I
always hated the setup of a I tried like
a nice camera one time I bought a used
one off eBay and I mean it looked great
but like the setup of that thing and
it's so kind of clunky and cumbersome
had a lot of issues with it would just
like lose its connection sometimes
and so this is a webcam from uh it's a
company I'd never heard of but I watched
a couple YouTube videos on it insta 360.
sorry I just blind you guys because I
had to
and it I mean it's like a 300 webcam but
it's
I think I got it I got it a little bit
cheaper than that I think that's like
the regular price
but um it's been great and I can't get
over the low light performance welcome
to Griffin a webcam should not the low
light performance on a webcam should not
be this great
all right so we have so when lowercase
Logan gifted out those memberships uh
five people Neil Harrison Tom Snipes Ayo
Rob Nathan Senate sinat Maybe
and Jacob Peterson all got one of those
gifted memberships so two games to play
lowercase Logan thank you all so much if
you got one of those gifted memberships
make sure you think lowercase Logan
there in the chat uh and then we have uh
we got a new subscriber demon subscribe
to the channel Christy gifting out a
tier one membership to I show sped don't
believe I've seen that name in here
before welcome thank you for being here
all right I gotta change the music this
is like two
ever since we got the annoying copyright
things
let's try
let's try this one
let's try this one
Dylan with a five dollar Super Chat
ghosty and spiders are still here I know
right
so they're actually tied to the alerts
and see I thought I got I got a surprise
for you guys on the next uh
that's not really any alert but the next
little screen
I got a surprise for you guys but I'm uh
I'm gonna try to let me let me get rid
of the uh
I'll get rid of the
spiders first on this one
but man I know like I I take one week
and it feels like so much time has
passed but
not a lot in the Hogwarts Legacy World
though so it's not we didn't miss a
whole lot we missed the uh we didn't get
to talk about
imperio yet so we'll talk about that for
sure
but Dylan thank you so much for the five
dollar Super Chat
radical Tyrell with another five gifted
you guys are going crazy with the
gifteds right now
Ravenclaw Tyrell thank you so much
dude Zack Morris in the house Zach
Morris just got one of those
I remember that name
because we definitely talked about it
and commented on it
so we're gonna get the five people who
just got gifted and lowercase Logan with
a super chat now won't be able to stick
around tonight have a date yo
good luck indeed my friend that's
awesome
well appreciate you stopping by for a
bit Hope your date goes well hope you
have a great time
and thank you so much for the Super Chat
and for all those gifted memberships
all right so we gotta go into our
streaming tools here my overlays
and this is going to be on our
yep there's the spider and there's the
ghost I just need to turn them off save
this
and there they're gone
there they're gone now
and now dealing with the tin are you
kidding me the tin gifted memberships
all right get ready for
yeah get ready for them to go crazy
there with the alerts Dylan dude thank
you so much
oh
how are you welcome to Gryffindor
I hope you guys like nearly headless
Nick
[Music]
I probably do need to change this to
something to make it a little bit
shorter
because when we get the night we get the
repeat like this
can't stay late tonight gotta show love
hey it's all good Dylan
Dylan whether you can stay five minutes
or the whole stream always appreciate it
my friend I I do always see you in the
replay Squad too Dylan so
speaking of that I got to figure out how
to uh apparently YouTube
I I have some setting on my channel
where people put hashtag something it
blocks the comment and I have to go in
and manually approve it which I don't
know I guess it detects it as a link or
something
so yeah some people will comment hashtag
replay Squad and it doesn't post their
comment so now see like right there why
did it only go through it didn't go
through the full tin that that received
the gift of membership from Dylan
I don't know why
I have no idea why all right so who all
is in the house tonight
let's jump back here
we got one up VR that is the very first
comment
that I see tonight very first comment
one up VR Professor Abbott in the house
again I'm pretty sure it was you
Professor Abbott I saw a comment about
um
oh no that was there were people way in
here way earlier than that let me see if
I can find it
Professor Abbott made a comment about
how they always look forward to
Wednesday or Tuesday
the Tuesday night stream
and I'm telling you man just hearing
that it really does like
it's so nice to hear so nice to hear
because last week
man I was so exhausted from it was a
crazy couple of weeks honestly at work
and then we had Halloween so the kids we
were I mean not out late but out late
for being with having kids out
so by the time we got home and you know
then they wouldn't have a little bit of
candy so as a parent it's like okay you
gotta let them have some candy
and then balance that with uh keep
making sure they don't just Gorge
themselves on it too much so we stayed
up a little bit later with them
but yeah man I just uh
I just didn't have the energy for it
last week so appreciate you guys all uh
showing up and being here tonight
but I did see your comment about how you
always look forward to the stream so how
are you I really do appreciate you
saying that all right I'm gonna try to
scroll back here we got another Channel
member
we'll see who is that right there Maisie
the dog has renewed their membership
makes you think oh no that was another
gifted another gifted from Christy
and then we had all of those uh popping
through with Dylan looks like Kathy and
Christopher and brocky GK
now see then if I actually click on
Dylan's I can see Olimar got it gifted
membership right there Lee Got A Gifted
soft-spoken one got a gifted Nathan
Ethan Aaron and then GK I think we
already mentioned GK
all right yeah it doesn't look like
it'll let me I can't go back
okay no not top chat I want to see all
the live chat
and still I scroll all the way back up
and it doesn't let me see everything
that's weird
well anyways my apologies if I missed
your comments early on but I'm going
back now I'm gonna shout out everyone
who's here hanging out right now we got
one up VR Professor Abbott
zutara babe
I know I'm pronouncing that wrong you've
told me you've told me more than once
Alicia soundtrack is here as well
hallberry God of War Eve right oh man I
can't wait I was trying to replay
through the first one I don't think I'm
gonna be able to
I don't think I'm gonna be able to hold
off
Jake in the house as well Tom is here
Puppet Master Nico yo what's up Nico
getting that exclamation point Discord
in there
Professor Abbott we got Lauren D we got
B Barbie we got JJ we got Jenna we got
Neil Tom our ship excited to be here hey
I'm glad you're excited to be here my
friend I'm I am pumped dude taking that
week off I'm just like re-energized and
ready to go
James Channel member is here IMO Josh
one with the sword is here geeky nerds
retro guy gaming what's up my friend
uh let's see we already said JJ there's
Jake of course Christy is here as well
Jay Rossi in the house another Channel
member what's up Jay Rossi Katrina
McKinney is here Jagged wizard
uh
we said James or we got Patty foot
weight Nintendo switch version is
digital
more on that in a second more on that in
a second
it's not for sure yet I'll tell you that
much uh Moon Lily is here Nightwing
D Jane Alicia we already said Alicia
Logan the other Logan
uppercase Logan Logan Isom is here in
the house no profile name welcomed
and then we got Noob hey Noob what's up
there's I show spit I think Azure sped
got one of those gifteds
and we got Neil oh stream elements
finally decided to show up nice of you
to do that Jason Hodges in the house
and D Jane is here once again we are
starting strong DJing Zachary Morris you
the man hey thank you Zack do you go by
Zachary or do you go by Zach I had a one
of my best friends in grade school
I see I don't want to assume because I'm
a Jonathan and a lot of times people
call me John like if they don't know me
really well and I don't I do not go by
John
people that know me well my closest
friends my family I am not John I'm
Jonathan so I don't want to assume but
most Zachary's I know they go by Zach
Christy with another Super Chat let's
see my local GameStop doing a midnight
event hey I miss midnight launch events
I ordered the uh I did order the
collector's edition of God of War
probably gonna be doing a unboxing for
uh for the channel of it
talking about how it's a way better
value than
I I the the highest God of War actually
did too they had the collectors and then
they had the yotinar Edition the yotinar
Edition is 260.
still less than the Hogwarts one but
even the collector's edition which is
199 has more stuff than the Hogwarts one
WB man they they dropped the ball on
that one they dropped the ball a bit
sin mermaid in the house new dog is here
as well
let's see anybody else new Chase
Productions
welcome my friend
we already got Moon Lily we already got
Lauren D we got a new dog we got Christy
we got Dylan in the house as well brocky
brocky just got uh one of those gifteds
I believe looking forward to buying the
merch yo thank you so much bro Rocky we
got more on the way if you're a member
of the Discord I've posted there to get
some feedback from you guys our next one
is going to be a Wizards chess club
design
and I thought I had the design finalized
and then I came up with a much more
simplified version which I kind of like
better
so I'm either going to do one or the
other or both
that's where we're at right now Geek
Squad
how's it going deep Squad David Lynch 89
days until early access for Hogwarts
Legacy it's crazy guys it's crazy I'm
telling you man 2023 is going to be here
before you know it and once 2023 gets
here it's just
I mean it's right around the corner it's
right around the corner
okay we got Bella here as well oh Bella
got one of the gifteds also Mark got one
of the gifteds Sonika soneka King got
one of the gifteds
Megan my name is Megan Ferguson welcome
Megan Ferguson thank you so much for
being here hanging out
on this glorious Tuesday evening
yeah not much Hogwarts Legacy news but a
lot a lot of gaming related stuff
happening lately
lots of gaming related stuff there's
Olimar there's Christopher there's Kathy
there's Nathan again
Sith Ray with the five dollar Super Chat
happy to catch the stream hope you and
the fan are excited the fam are excited
for Thanksgiving oh yeah yeah my wife
has to work unfortunately but that means
she gets off Christmas and New Year so
most of you most of the regulars know my
wife's a nurse so she the way they kind
of do their holidays is they they get
one of the they get at least one of the
big three between for us in the US
that's Thanksgiving Christmas and New
Year's
and if you've been there for a while
have a little bit more seniority then a
lot of times you can get two off so
she's got to work Thanksgiving this year
but then she's gonna have both uh
Christmas Eve Christmas Day and then
she'll have New Year's Eve New Year's
day as well so that's good
so she always gets at least here lately
she's been getting two of the three but
yeah we're still gonna try to get down
and see my family for a bit
and then uh she'll have to come back and
we'll probably stay a little bit longer
but she works like 12 hour shifts anyway
so when she's working like that she
barely she barely has time to even I
mean get home have dinner and go to
sleep pretty much
all right we are almost caught up here
in the chat Jordan hey what's up Jordan
catching a live stream while dashing
love the channel keep it up hey thanks
Jordan appreciate it
can we talk about the beard though dude
I know right it's like
it's getting pretty it's I haven't
trimmed it in a while so is it as it
gets colder
kind of just gotta let it you know
let it let it keep going I've been using
like a new beard wash too
that's like the second this guy at work
the other day was like dude the beard is
like
well well thank you I did uh I did try a
new try new beard wash and haven't
trimmed it lately so
another mad night for nearly headless
Nick right we always keep nearly
headless Nick busy our Chef what a nice
Community for real
for real very nice Community
holy gotta be very careful how I say
your name because this is a
family-friendly stream but welcome glad
you're here thanks for hanging out
12 hour shifts I know right
CJ is in the house as well oh oh I
missed a couple people though Bradley
Roberts Bradley Channel member here in
the house high IQ Warrior we got
Ravenclaw Tyrell earlier we see Jenny as
well
and then there's Jay Rossi
uh a different Chris Chris Berkland
second Hogwarts Legacy looking forward
to God of War Ragnarok I'm I'm so pumped
Gabe here as well yeah Mew store talking
about the uh
that collector's edition Beastie as well
yours is doing an event at 11 for God
award nice nice
super nige glad I could make it normally
Camp because it's late in the UK oh man
yeah it's really late for you all over
there right now
dude that's the crazy thing about our
audience too it's so global
I I don't know why but I wasn't when the
channel started taking off a little bit
I wasn't prepared for that
because uh I streamed on Twitch for a
while and you know had had a
had a few regulars who would trickle him
but it was never anywhere close to this
in terms of like the global nature I
mean we have people from all over every
single stream I mean I think that speaks
to it speaks to YouTube it speaks to the
Harry Potter fandom as well
but it's just awesome but I do apologize
if I uh these are always uh early in the
early hours of the morning for a lot of
people but that's why I do keep them up
so you can uh
they always stay the vods stay on the
YouTube channel which
let me go ahead and switch over
the or division
for Chad or thank you so much for
supporting the stream did you guys
notice I pronounced it correctly I did
retro hope all is well passing to wish
everyone a great stream also do you
think Hogwarts Legacy news will slow
down for the holidays
that is a great question thanks so much
for the Super Chat once again as well I
think you could be right
I was that was gonna be one of my topics
tonight we've got
two kind of big topics and then one sort
of smaller topic that was going to be
one of the big topics because
well let's just go ahead let's just go
ahead and get into it here let's go
ahead ladies and gentlemen
all right
oh yeah so I mentioned I have something
new
look at that look at that down there at
the bottom you guys
look at that
all those new members all those new
super chats hopefully it doesn't get too
distracting we'll try it we'll try it
for a stream and see how it goes
I think I have it slowed down enough
where it's not too distracting but if
you guys want it to slow down even more
I can we can slow down the text even
more if we need to
so just let me know what you all think
1 50 a.m Wednesday
for Ryan ten to two for me
Arcane exotic locations such as the US
Midwest I mean the majority of audiences
us yeah for sure
can't wait to get the platinum trophy I
show sped all right for uh
well I don't know if you're talking
about God of War or Hogwarts Legacy but
yeah I can't wait to get it in both of
those yo Bradley Roberts now with the 10
super chat thanks for keeping the page
going by far the most dedicated page to
the
the title oh Hogwarts Legacy hey Bradley
thank you so much for the Super Chat
there's a lot of good Hogwarts Legacy
creators out there but yeah we we've
been doing it for a while
covering the game for a while and
speaking of that that last question do I
think things will slow down so here's
what I wanted to talk about
if you look at this our last update
was on October 31st Halloween so it's
been more than a week and correct me if
I'm wrong you guys
I think this is the longest they've went
for a while without without something
I mean it's not there's not been a
little drop or anything now this isn't
me it's not a critique or anything more
just an observation because I mean the
news had been just popping on the
regular you know I mean if we go all the
way back to
so like here we are early September back
to Hogwarts day that kicked off a hole
just set of posts that they announced
all of the how you could connect it with
uh your wizard house from The Wizarding
World website
the wands they they announced the house
fanatic robes then we got the common
room tour so I mean they were really
pumping that out then September 13th the
haunted hogsmeat shop we got all that
info got a new trailer for that so
didn't see even like the next day
September 14th your wise to be weary
they posted that September 15th watch
your step September 16th so even though
it was kind of re-sharing a lot of
things
it was pretty steady pretty frequent fat
lady September 20th so they kind of
continued this
all the way so then we go September 30th
October 3rd October 5th October 7th on
October 12th so we had a five-day Gap
right there
then they had the grand staircase on the
18th two posts that day then we had okay
so there was a bit of a gap right here
between this one
so October 18th to the 26th 26th so
eight days right there
I love this little uh this little
animation right here by the way
so then we go from the 26th to a double
post on the 26th because we also got the
info on the
official game guide
then on Halloween so five days later
after that so they have kind of been
starting to spread things out a bit on
Halloween we got the imperius reveal
which I was kind of surprised by that I
thought
I even said it on the channel here that
I thought it was going to be
the ASMR I did
I thought it was going to be the next
ASMR video so some people kind of
disappointed by this I wasn't
disappointed but I was just I guess I
was a little a little bit surprised that
it wasn't the ASMR and we still don't
have it
we still don't have it that's kind of
like a low hanging fruit one too I feel
like they have that ready to go
it's just a matter of when there was
that rumor that they actually uh
shared it out and then quickly took it
down so I don't know if that was true or
not
ASMR Christmas video how magical that be
I agree I think the but see that would
be winter if they get into Chris the
Christmas season and I thought like I
I thought that would be a perfect time
for the winter one so would they really
I mean if they don't release this here
in the first in the next couple weeks or
so I mean I would say next week week and
a half
the fall ASMR then I mean then you're in
a winter
so
that's kind of weird
I can't I can't imagine they would just
skip it I can't imagine they would do
that
need to drop some gameplay soon that's
the other thing
because they have promised that we will
get gameplay before the end of the year
or I guess before next year
we still don't have there's all those
rumors on the the Sony event
why is the Xbox says require oh I don't
Jake I don't think that's anything to
worry about that's just the uh they talk
about it on the official FAQ as well
like
that's gonna be for like the day one
patch
there's there's nothing I don't think
there's any kind of like Secret
there's there's nothing they're trying
to hide I don't think
yeah Professor rabbit I am I'm East
Coast so for me it is almost 9 00 p.m
here almost 9 P.M
like Wall Street zodiac I know right
with with the scroll down there
we could scroll we could slow it down
just a tad Maybe
I think that's on like a level four and
I could drop it down to three or two
and I think it shows like the last 25
items so I should scroll for a bit
but yeah so I I feel like things are
maybe they are starting to wind down now
a lot of people always talk about well
on the holidays there's lots of vacation
that's true but as I've shared with many
of you before I work in marketing as
well and do a lot of the social media
for the organization I work for and
it's not like you can't post during the
holidays you just have all of it I'm
taking off too but we're gonna have all
that stuff batched and ready to go
so they could batch some things and have
it lined up
so I don't think that's a reason for
them not to have any posts around the
holidays I think we'll get something
I would be I would be very shocked if we
didn't have the uh
like you said a winter ASMR around
Christmas just feels like
it feels like it's meant to be
wonder if they will do previews soon by
Outlets
I'm curious too Sean I'm curious too I
will um I'll let you guys know if I hear
anything
but I know all of the all of the main
Hogwarts Legacy YouTubers that you guys
watch and enjoy we are all
in the same boat kind of hoping hoping
that we will uh
yeah we don't know we have no idea we
have no idea if we'll get a like a
review code for the game early or what
dude that's crazy to think about though
right that there were I mean once once
the new year gets here January
oh I mean January 7th would be a month
out from the 72 hour
release of February 7th be a month out
so I don't know I don't know if they do
like a one week if they do two week if
they do a month I have no idea
so we'll just wait and see
and cross our fingers for
more delays
or fingers
until it goes gold man until it is
shipped until it is physically mailed
I will not I will not count it as a
given until it happens
Ryan topics fantastic piece canceled new
I mean I don't know that so much
Fantastic Beasts canceled just that
they said there's nothing currently in
development but I guess it kind of is
canceled sort of because they had
originally planned for five movies I
believe
although the positive I took away from
that news story though was that the uh
the new Warner Brothers CEO it sounds
like they want to do more Harry Potter
stuff there's just nothing currently in
development
I think they need to go
more towards either
something like
a lot of people want to see something
around the Marauders that time time
frame
or even after Harry gets older or maybe
even after like like the Next Generation
like after
like when Harry is a grandfather or
something or maybe even after Harry
passes away maybe something after that
so many possibilities you know
what would I do if they had to delay the
game again
man
I mean it depends on how long it would
be right David if they're like guys we
need like there's like we're on the
finishing stretch there's like a couple
more things we gotta tighten up the new
date is February 25th or something
I'd be like okay
that's fine but that's it that's it if
they're like
guys we're gonna have to delay it to the
second half of 2020. then I would get
worried I'd get worried
or if it's like two month delay or
something oh yeah that'd be rough
Professor Abbott thinks the ASMR will
reveal the companion hey it's possible
they could do that as well like fall
ASMR somebody said fall Autumn ASMR
around Thanksgiving yeah that's true
that's true as well
yeah so for the um
I see some of you are asking about the
switch now
[Music]
imagine ads have to roll around
Christmas because of higher viewership
uh what do you what do you mean zodiac
you talking about for Hogwarts Legacy
stuff Dylan with are you serious still
in what in the world another Super Chat
a 20 Super Chat from Dylan
oh my goodness Dylan dude
thank you so much Dylan always showing
mad support you guys mad support 20
Super Chat and he says don't forget to
hit that like button
ding and if you want some awesome merch
there you go retro record tour
excuse me
dot Creator hyphenspring.com or
retroecontour.com
if you can't remember that Dylan the
link will be in Dylan's Super Chat there
but
you can always go to retroacting
tour.com as well and that will work you
can just hit merch from there but yeah
we're getting ready to add a new one
here pretty soon
I made the mistake of putting Hogwarts
in the uh I was actually listing it the
other day
and I made the mistake of putting
Hogwarts in the uh the little bio the
description
and it detected it as like copyright as
I was like oh no
there's nothing copyrighted about this
shirt so I'm gonna have to go in and
redo it when I have the time
yeah a couple you're saying you think
they could do it around Thanksgiving
don't say that I don't right I know
why is slow mode on uh Lauren because
you see how far behind I am already
that's why to help to help me try and
keep up a little bit although we did
learn and a couple streams ago we did
learn that if you have a membership even
if you were gifted if you're paying gift
paying Channel member or if you were
gifted a channel member
you do not you're not subject to slow
mode which I had no idea so that's why
even when I have slow mode on the chat
keeps flowing because we have so many
members here who are active in the chat
want to see the founders oh it'd be cool
if they went back that far
something on another school now see
Jenny something like that I think would
be a great idea because it really opens
up
you don't have to I mean you have to
worry about the lore a little bit
a little bit but that gives you the
opportunity to just almost completely Do
Your Own Thing
and you don't have to worry about
sacrificing too much of the of the lore
Eddie said it to
I'm not sure what you're saying Ryan
Eddie Redmayne maybe a Tom Riddle movie
is already planned they want to focus
more on Harry Potter
hmm interesting
hate when shows introduce new cast
members
yeah exactly Noob the chat does get
hectic sometimes
Theo when will the game go gold uh
usually
like let's see
like let's see uh so we'll just say
Ragnarok gone gold because God of War
Ragnarok comes out tomorrow
so about a
about a month ago
God of War Ragnarok went gold on October
7th
and then the game is coming out tomorrow
November 9th
so yeah I mean we should early January
guys
early January
dude that is just insane that is so
insane for me to think about
three hours till God of War opens up
let's go
foreign
must be nearly gold the German rating
yeah we've been getting a lot more of
the ratings lately
Christy with a 99 Christie thank you so
much for the Super Chat I don't see a
comment with that one Christy I'm not
sure if you were
if you were just showing a little love
or if you meant to have a comment but
thank you so much either way
for all the support here
uh well no they're not playing Josh new
movies are not planned that they made
that very clear that there's nothing
currently in development
regarding Harry Potter however
they want to do more
want to do more which would be great
how do you turn that on oh you talk
about slow so it's something I can
enable before the Stream
the the slow-mo thing
Raphael Raphael
I just joined what I miss only have the
switch to the stream helps me all right
well we hadn't got to that point yet
Raphael so
that's what we are getting ready to talk
about is the switch stuff
Moon Lily would love to see ilvermorny
any of the other schools super intrigued
with the Japan School
party believer in November it really is
Neil it really is
yes I'm finally called up Tom we finally
got there
all right so if you guys haven't been
following
the switch thing has been
bizarre from the get-go in Hogwarts
Legacy
so I'm gonna go
I'm just gonna pull up my channel here
and I'm gonna go to my recent videos
scroll down
okay this video here
so
when they first announced Hogwarts
Legacy
at the PlayStation
showcase for the PS5 reveal
there was no mention of Nintendo switch
no mention
then when they did the big stay to play
where they they showed us all the
gameplay which was a long time after
that first trailer
they didn't even talk about it a lot in
the
in the in the they didn't talk about it
all in the presentation
but then after we found out oh
it's also coming to switch
which I don't think anybody was
expecting
no one was expecting that and so one of
the first questions that people
immediately started asking and wondering
about is
how is that running on the Nintendo
switch
how is that running
I'll turn on receiving gifts oh yeah
yeah
oh there you go yeah the chat's got you
I don't think it pops up until you're
A Gifted one though but I could be wrong
I could be wrong trust trust the chat
over me on that
so I made this video right here which
has been one of our most viewed Hogwarts
Legacy videos hope this Hogwarts Legacy
rumor isn't true and so this is all
about
the switch version and how
there's there's a couple possibilities
here
how are they going to get it to run
that's the question right
it seems to be split about 50 50 in
terms of what people think about half
the people think that it's going to be a
native version it's going to be a
version built for the switch
and it will
just be very all the settings will be
very turned down just be just be way
turned out
like The Witcher yeah exactly
that's possible
some things that back this up
we've seen the box art for it
a lot of people point out there's a
boxer there's a deluxe edition for it
you can pre-order it on Best Buy on
Amazon on GameStop it's there to
pre-order
so would they really make a hard would
they really make a physical box and the
box art for the switch if it was digital
only
or the cloud only haven't got to that
part yet so my stance was always just
because they they have the box there I
would not take that as being given that
hey this is a native version developed
for the ground up
for the switch
so that's one possibility
the other possibility which we see with
some games I have personally not played
any game like this on the switch but
there are more and more of these games
because the console is so ridiculously
popular and Nintendo just doesn't seem
to care about putting out an updated
version
the install base is so huge on the
switch so people developing these new
games they're trying to find ways to get
things running on the switch so instead
of instead of making it for them for the
ground up
or just like toning down their settings
they're developing Cloud versions of
these titles
and so what that means is that whenever
you play it on your switch
it's digital only
and rather than you
running that game on your switch you're
actually communicating with a Cloud
Server and you're playing the game
on all the highest settings so that'd be
that'd be the positive of that you would
have a great looking experience on the
switch great looking experience and
probably good frame rates too
the negatives of that
first of all it kills one of the biggest
advantages of the switch and that you
can't play on the go unless you're I
don't you know you got Wi-Fi in your car
or your
playing on your mobile hotspot whatever
it may be but you're gonna have to have
internet with you if you're going to
play on the go
that would be a big downside the other
big downside is you are
it's entirely based on your internet
connection so if you have a poor
connection the game's going to run
poorly
if you have a any kind of interference
with the connection it's going to run
poorly
so there's all kinds of little issues
that that would bring up if that were
the case now
again I've seen some people in both
camps some people would think that oh I
want that because I want the I've got a
great Wi-Fi I actually prefer that I
don't want them to have to turn down any
of the settings release it for a cloud
version on the switch think that'd be
great and other people like what no my
internet's terrible I want to be able to
have the copy on my system and for me
like I am very susceptible to input lag
and any cloud gaming I've ever tried I
can always detect just a little bit of
input lag my kids were playing the other
day
um there's a couple of titles through
PlayStation Plus that you can only
stream
and it's gotten a lot better I will say
it has gotten a lot better but to be
fair my PS5 is hardwired in to my to my
modem so there's no Wi-fi interference
at all I'm hardwired in
now if you have the first version of the
switch you don't have that option unless
you buy the extra USB dongle thing that
lets you connect ethernet if you have
the OLED switch then you do have
ethernet so you can connect straight in
but I just think it ruins like one of
the biggest benefits of a switch right
is the portable nature of it
so I made this video here talking about
I hope I hope this rumor isn't true and
we talk about uh this has since been
updated on the official site
um but there's been so much craziness
then when they finally announced the
release date they say that oh here yeah
this was in my video here so this was
back in this was five months ago so I'm
sure this list is longer now but this
was from Nintendo life here these are
some games for the Nintendo switch that
run on the cloud so Marv Guardians of
the Galaxy
a very popular game a very good game on
the next-gen systems and even on uh PS4
and Xbox One
but the switch version is a cloud
version then a couple of these Kingdom
Hearts titles Dying Light two a plague
tale Requiem so that that game just came
out I don't know if that's
I actually have no idea if it came out
on the switch yet or not or if it was if
it's delayed
let me let me actually look that up so
plague
tail requiem
switch
yeah there it is right here on
Nintendo's website
oh geez age verification
1980.
download demo okay so they do have
and it looks like they do have to have
to let people know that it is a cloud
version only that's what I keep saying
dude like if this is the case for
Hogwarts Legacy they really need to let
some people know and I've I've asked
I've tried to get confirmation from
Chandler or anybody and nobody's
nobody's saying anything about the
switch version right now
so there's that
then nothing has been said about this
like I made this video
May 27th is when I made this video
nobody said much of anything about the
Nintendo switch version all this time we
still have the box arts on Amazon on
Best Buy all the websites you can still
see the box art
and so people were starting to feel
pretty confident okay they've got the
box art they haven't said it's a cloud
version so it's probably going to be a
hard copy version right
well not so fast
someone tagged me on Twitter
let's see a few days ago
let me go to my mentions here
right
here so Steven on Twitter or underscore
the Ariel on Twitter just saw this on
the website I use in the UK and it seems
like the switch version is going to be
digital only even if you buy the
physical box now for any of you in the
UK watching right now I'm gonna need
your help here
because I do not know much about this
shop 2 website I don't know how
how reliable of a retailer they are are
they pretty reputable if you go to the
website
I mean no matter where you live
um anybody can go to their website right
here shop2.net I mean it looks like a
legitimate
looks like a legitimate site where you
can can purchase games and such
and if you go into category and you
search Hogwarts Legacy I tested this
myself after I got that tweet
so we're going to hit search here
and then go down to the look at this
they've updated their switch version to
where it says Hogwarts Legacy code in
box
now that's for the standard version
let's see because the deluxe does not
say this let's say the deluxe edition
let's see what happens when we click on
it
okay that's interesting that one
that one doesn't say it
this is interesting you guys
I'm almost positive the other day
uh I don't wanna let me see oh actually
I can go back to my Twitter right here
because I oh no it was the same right
here look at this yeah so even then
Hogwarts likes he deluxe edition said
nothing about code in box
but then the standard edition says code
in box
that is so interesting foreign
looking in the chat any of you in the UK
any of you in the UK that have this uh
are familiar with the site any pro that
have prices slashed instantly you don't
trust I know right
I mean because it like it has that look
of a site that's like
it could be legit I mean it looks like
GameStop
then there's also a lot of kind of
interesting like hmm oh let me see if
they have a Twitter
oh wait okay hold on
60 000 followers on Twitter followed by
Warner Brothers games UK and Ireland
okay
leading online video games retailer
accessories and consoles with finance
options available I mean maybe they are
legit
let's check their uh Instagram
not as many followers there
but yeah I mean the fact that the
official WB account follows them
that is interesting never mind then I
know it's like it's it could be
nobody here nobody watching right now in
the UK Noob okay Noob says in the UK
person wouldn't trust this okay there we
go
yeah like I have no frame of reference
whatsoever for this shop 2 website
zero frame of reference so I have no
idea
DJ Darth Starkiller says no not legit
okay all right so that's two people I'm
assuming you're in the UK as well saying
probably not legit let me think of a
game isn't there isn't the big one in
the UK called game
Alicia probably wouldn't buy from them
either
yeah game dot co uk okay so this is this
is legit right this is a site a lot of
you
buy from
love game okay all right all right let's
see if they have anything like this
oh okay here we go here we go Hogwarts
Legacy there's the switch version
okay let's go to the standard one
49.99
sold and fulfilled by game
yeah I'm not seeing anything here about
this
but
regardless of whether the site is valid
or not we still don't know the answer
because it is possible that's what I
always said to people like it's possible
they could actually ship you a box
with nothing but the code in it
they could ship you a box with nothing
but the code in it
and if that is true if that part is true
that they're only doing Hogwarts Legacy
for the switch as a digital only then
for me that would that would really lend
Credence to the belief that it is cloud
only
and and the other thing I keep going
back to is if it's if it's not Cloud
only
why not just come out and say that
you know
why wouldn't they just just say like
retro stop talking
oh man
it's a it's it's a native version there
will be a cartridge for the switch
why wouldn't they just say that
because there's weird stuff regardless
going on with the switch version because
it doesn't have the same release date so
we also know that too
so yeah I it's like that's a good point
super fishy that it that they have the
uh
they already have prices slashed so I
don't know if we would trust it
but I do think it's definitely something
to keep an eye out on
and that doesn't just have to be UK
retailers you know we could look at um
hold on let me make sure I don't have
any of my
pull up these gaming websites that I
shop on
like let me make sure
I don't have any of my personal
information
visible all right so I'm gonna go to
Best Buy that's one of our
big ones here
in the U.S okay so for Hogwarts like the
Nintendo switch
yeah nothing nothing yet
nothing yet
away specifications here
they don't even they don't have the uh
okay all right all right all right all
right so this is this is on the other
side so on the on the Best Buy website
so let me open up a window so you guys
can see this right here
Best Buy actually giving us some
positives
on the other side if we go right
down to the specifications
software format it says physical
but again
take that with a grain of salt they're I
feel like they would assume that it's
physical until they until they got
otherwise you know
good talk switch always gets hurt I mean
right and even even no matter what the
switch version is going to be inferior I
mean it just is
it just is have they really said
anything about switch JP raven fire
what's up by the way other than that's
right JP that's it
that is it
and I can't wait to ask
I don't know if
I don't know if I know podcast now has
had Troy on a couple times I have no
idea if Troy would be able to answer
this
I know Troy sometimes watches some of my
YouTube videos so Troy if you happen to
see this and you know the answer and you
can say
uh hit me up because I would love to
know I almost feel like it was something
that was added
after the initial reveal
and if that were the case I feel like
that
that tilts things even more toward the
cloud the cloud path
Zone M24 here in the house as well
what's up I think there's a chance they
canceled the switch version I don't
think they will cancel it
but man there's something weird going on
there's there's definitely something
weird going on
no release date
won't say if it's a cloud version or
hard copy version
which took to be fair to I feel like I
feel like the majority of people don't
even like just kind of the mainstream
aren't even aware that like this whole
Cloud stuff is a thing on the switch
I mean even me as someone who's really
plugged in to the gaming industry it was
several months ago when I I can't
remember what title I I came across
it may have been Guardians of the Galaxy
and I just kept thinking what this is a
thing on the switch
this is a thing Christy gotta head out
replay Squad the rest leaving to take a
nap before midnight release oh nice hey
enjoy
I'm gonna I'm gonna try to avoid
spoilers all week because I don't think
I'll get I'm not gonna get much time to
play it this week I don't think
but yeah hopefully by the weekend I'll
be ready to play
Shadow guided sorry I'm late yo it's all
good
I know yeah Toys R Us I love Toys R Us
I think Alicia was asking do we have uh
CeX no not that I'm familiar with so our
biggest for video games our biggest are
Best Buy
GameStop
um if you do online Amazon of course and
even like Target Walmart for a lot of
people as well and then
um
oh there's a couple more
as well but those those are the big ones
for sure
sleazy side just wants to sell prior
right yeah
could be
Stacy you're new here welcome Stacy
thank you so much for hanging out we got
a great Community here
a very friendly Community I'm sure you
will be uh hopefully you'll feel right
at home in no time and then Shadow
guided with a super chat it's not much
but here here retro for being Shadow
guided oh come on now you didn't have to
do that shadow guided but thank you so
much guys honestly just you being here
hanging out
supporting the stream is is huge guys
it's huge
never never feel obligated like you have
to uh donate or anything
maybe Toys R Us website has some info I
know it's right well I don't think
Toys R Us doesn't exist anymore
wait what
did they actually bring them back
because wait this is current November
8th
and November 8th is steam day
wait do they just have like the online
still going
I'm so confused
let's see games
maybe they're just like trying to get
rid of their
nah surely they would have gotten rid of
all that by now
I'm so confused right now
thank you
uh like they don't have any locations
listed
[Music]
follow us on Twitter what are they let's
see what their
they have 1.8 million followers
oh this is recent so wait they were
tweeting
oh
do you have a Toys R Us at Macy's
yo that's interesting are they trying to
do it
Toys R Us is back
so they're they're trying kind of a
different business model maybe like
they're just inside other stores right
now
online maybe but any actual store no
yeah I guess except for
completely abandoned for years yeah our
the store that we had went went out
coming to certain stores this holiday
season think Macy's is the partner there
we go Neil dude that's kind of exciting
yeah I mean they were they were
definitely active
active on Twitter so
yeah it doesn't look like they have any
games at all on the website so we kind
of went down a bit of a rabbit hole
there but
you know what we could try we could try
uh we could try GameStop
as well
let's see if GameStop has anything
because I do try to check periodically
just to see what they're if they've got
any updates on
I keep looking for Collector's Editions
for James as well
poor James I know he's still trying to
get a collector's
okay so for
let's see on the GameStop site they
don't have anything there either
about like what what kind of version it
is
Blockbuster right
hey Nathan welcome
wait which Nathan is that I think one
Nathan
oh it was Nathan Senate who got the A
Gifted member wolf spirit Toys R Us
never closed in Canada still have lots
of them for real
oh that's awesome
EB Games got a key ring oh yeah we don't
have EB Games here in the US anymore
either
volte welcome to the Stream volte
that's true Jenny that's true
Rob I have no oh I think Rob just
deleted the comment I have no idea to
your question though
I have no idea
Go Ninja Go what's up welcome what did
you miss uh we're just talking about
Hogwarts Legacy So for anybody who's
dropping into the stream right now we're
talking about the switch version of
Hogwarts Legacy and whether or not it's
a cloud version only
and what the heck's going on with it
like they they said we'll announce the
release date soon
back when they first announced the
release date for everything else and and
I keep trying to find this out because I
always have people in my comments I
almost always have somebody in the chat
too who posts about
that they're they only have a switch
there's someone in in James Community
expect a ghost Community who
um the community bought them a Nintendo
switch to play this game
to be able to play this game
and
I I mean I don't feel like there's a lot
of people in that boat but there are
definitely it's a significant number of
people that I feel like they need
answers
they need some answers
delete the comment oh text to speech
type the whole thing out incorrect maybe
James will get collectors on Amazon when
the releases they got restock on Gotham
Knights and God of War Ragnarok oh nice
dude do they have the yotnar God of War
Ragnarok I'm gonna check that right now
I'd love to do an unboxing for that
I've got a uh
collectors pre-ordered for God of War
but not the
the collectors I've seen oh yeah it's
actually still available right now on
Amazon if any of you are interested in
the
Ragnarok collector's edition
but um I keep checking on Amazon too for
the yote Gnar and haven't seen it come
back in stock
let me check Target one more time that's
where I got my
nope
I really hope James gets one though
because he he's like one of the few
people I know who really really wants
one
I mean I might I honestly I might just
sell mine to him for regular
just for regular price
got the collectors all I need is that
sweet Hammer right Gabe
oh
Shadow guided yeah yeah
the physical
um
that's the yotnar or no you're yeah your
prices are a little bit different I bet
so for the US for God of War our
collector's edition is 199.
overall yeah the Hogwarts Legacy dude
it's insane it's insane
WB they they dropped the ball a bit
there I'll just say it
I'll just say it I mean everybody knows
it so
if you want to do a 300 collector's
edition like fine I'm not going to
object to that
you do what you want but
the items that they put in there for
three hundred dollars man
it's just a joke and I feel bad for
Avalanche be clear guys it's
it's not Avalanche that controls that
I I doubt very seriously that Avalanche
had much input at all on what was going
on with the Hogwarts ladies collector's
edition
you compare those side by side you
compare the God of War yotinar Edition
which is cheaper than the Hogwarts
Legacy collector's edition
and it's just night and day and then God
of War has a collector's edition
that includes way more for a hundred
dollars less
a hundred dollars less it's my it's
mind-blowing my biggest problem with the
God of War collectors edition is that it
doesn't include a physical copy of the
game like what what
what
how does it not include a physical copy
I think it's because uh
PlayStation has that digital only
console so they have to uh you know
why not just do two I mean you are you
actually did two versions you should
have just done one that was digital and
one that was
the uh The Collector should have just
been the digital and then the yotinar
should have been a physical copy
or something like that you know like if
you're already doing two editions anyway
but yeah that is one advantage for the
Hogwarts Legacy I think is that it
includes the a hard copy of the game
unless you're going the PC route
I still prefer hard copies most of my
games but
I don't know man I feel like it's just a
matter of time before they for I mean
for PC it's been that way for years
right
feel bad for Chandler in the unboxing I
know right
I know
and so part of me like I have one
pre-order I'm I'll be just totally
upfront with you guys I have one
pre-ordered I was able to get one in at
GameStop
and that's like I've really been going
back and forth in my mind about like do
I want to take a stand because on
principle like
just on principle unless you know if you
have a lot of disposable income and you
love the wand I'm not going to tell you
how to spend your money go for it but in
terms of like being someone to to
critique the the value of it
and whether I think you you should
pre-order like if you're kind of on the
fence like absolutely not I I only
pre-ordered it because
for one I think the wand would look kind
of cool right back here I do I think it
would look kind of cool floating back
there because I could see everybody
complains they hate the little uh they
hate the white chord showing I can hide
that very easily with my setup right
here it can go right down behind
this uh this little drawer and nobody
would ever see it so I don't care about
that and I do think it looks like I
actually think the wand is cool I I
think that was a cool idea but then
everything else around it I'm just like
that where where's the 300.
where where is the how are we getting to
the three hundred dollars here dude
oh
so I I'm not gonna tell you how to spend
your money but in terms of like value
heck no it's not even close to worth it
like even if it was a 200 this think
about this guys this is what's crazy
even if it was a 200 collector's edition
people would still probably be like a
little bit overpriced but not it's not
like egregious like just look at this if
you guys haven't seen
uh in the Ragnarok
and I don't mean to keep comparing it to
God of War Ragnarok but it's just like
this is another
this is a new
a game coming out around the same time
so here they are unboxing let me just
get to the
the new feature YouTube added you guys
seen this yet like as you're skimming if
you pull up
you get like this precise editor now
where they can uh you can see exactly
where you want to go
all right so
okay
hold on I want to wait till they sit it
all out on the table here
which I think is probably
right here
okay
so I'm just gonna speed it up okay so
here this is the collector's edition so
you get the steel book
you get the the die set right here you
get these statues
fast forward it make it make it go
quicker here
so you get the steel book
so Hogwarts Legacy has a steel book all
right and then here's some of the
digital stuff they're going to run
through
which I'm to the point where like
digital stuff just does not mean much to
me at all I just don't even care Mini
art book though that's kind of cool
kind of cool that you get the mini art
book so then they open it up
pretty cool box
and then
it comes with freaking Thor's hammer
so that's kind of the equivalent of the
of the wand in the Hogwarts psychase box
all right so let me see Does it include
anything else okay no now they're at the
yotinar so the yotinar is more expensive
okay so that right there
is God of Wars collector's edition
steelbook
Thor's hammer the statues and the dice
it's two hundred dollars
it's two hundred dollars
the Hogwarts Legacy one
comes with less
and it's 300 so let's say like let's say
now to be fair
I could see now the quality of this
Hammer I don't have it at hand to say
the quality of this looks A step above
the wand the wand does have the
electrical components and it kind of
does something a little bit more than
what the hammer does but at the end of
the day they're both they're gonna be
sitting on a shelf collecting dust
that's what they're gonna be
so let's just say those two cancel each
other out the wand and the hammer then
you got the steelbook so the steel book
cancels each other out the boxes cancel
each other out
and then that's it for Hogwarts Legacy
the digital stuff cancels each other out
so then they include this
and it's 100 cheaper
okay
but then here here's where it gets gets
even crazier like if Hogwarts like us he
wanted to go out all out if they wanted
to charge you know big money
look at this man so this is the yotinar
Edition so this one is 260 dollars
in the U.S
so we're still we're still forty dollars
cheaper than
the Hogwarts Legacy Collection Edition
all right so here we go so we got the we
got the statues again we got the dice I
think it's a different set of dice but
then it comes with this pin set as well
and then here's where it just gets
oh I forgot about this yeah it comes
with this little ring too
which whatever here's where it gets
amazing dude
like come on WB imagine if Hogwarts did
something like that
imagine if it doesn't have to be a map
imagine if they did a cloth version that
big of the box art dude that box art is
so gorgeous and it would have been
perfect because one side could have been
the the light like the good side and the
other side could have been the evil oh
such a missed opportunity or division
dude thank you so much for the Super
Chat I got the PS5 Hogwarts like it's a
collector's edition because of content
creation to support their creation it
hurt a little time to go to work wishing
you all a great stream mischief managed
or division that is pretty much I was I
started to tell that story and then I
got off on a tangent so thank you for
reminding me
I'm gonna be like I said I'm gonna be
honest with you guys I do have it
pre-ordered that is the main reason why
is is I as someone who is covering
Hogwarts Legacy I do feel like I need to
review it
and give it like an unbiased like I
actually paid 300 for this
and I think it's ridiculous
maybe in person maybe I'll open it up
and it will absolutely blow me away and
I'll just be like dude the quality the
craftsmanship on this is incredible yes
it's still overpriced but the one is
awesome I hope I hope that's what I can
say
but I don't expect it or thank you so
much for that Super Chat though I am
right in the same boat with you right in
the same boat with you
all right just catching back up on some
comments here
let's see the magic Caster ones are
beautiful but for 150 too much for my
taste like
they could have been
the point though
could have literally like you could buy
oh my gosh you could buy a magic Caster
wand
a freaking like it actually has some
some utility and the designs on them are
really cool now this is something you
actually need in terms of the utility no
but it's fun right
like you could get that that's 150 then
the game for even if you buy the deluxe
for eighty dollars
and you're still less than the way less
than the collection Edition
oh my goodness right oh my goodness
no profile name I was going to be
willing to make the stretch for the
collectors because of how much I love
Harry Potter I seen it was an easy right
it was super easy pass like even me guys
think about this as someone who is
covering this game as closely as I am
huge fan of Harry Potter
and I'm sitting here telling you guys
like I kind of think I'm Gonna Cancel my
pre-order I'm not gonna do that though
because I know James really does want it
so if I was going to cancel I would just
I could also do a giveaway too
I could do a giveaway for it
I don't know man I just don't like a ton
of items being around my house anyway I
watched a minimalism documentary a
couple years ago and I've really tried
to like not that I don't collect
anything but I really try and be
more strategic like the stuff that you
guys see back here are things that I
have I've been very careful about like
the link is special because that was a
gift from one of my good friends when
when I had my first son
so that's actually that's actually my my
oldest son's link right there but I've
always remembered that and then Infamous
one of my favorite games on the
PlayStation 3 I believe that was the
first ever collector's edition that I
bought and I still to this day use the
uh this is you guys probably can't see
too well right here oh the cam the
microphone's blocking it but
here I'll just hold it
this was the uh coal statue from the
Infamous games
and then this one also came with an
awesome backpack like the backpack that
he has in the game
it came with the actual backpack for
that that has the Sly Cooper patch on it
and then I have a little uh Harry Potter
dude this is old old right here
it's a little clock which is not correct
by the way it doesn't have batteries in
it but it's also kind of like a little
uh you could use it like a little
bookend or something
and then I have my Samus amiibo that is
the single amiibo oh no wait I do have
hold on I have another amiibo I lied
back here I'm a big Metroid fan so I
haven't even opened this one
foreign
amiibo
so anyway my point is I'm very
particular about my my Collector's
Editions and all that
but we're not we're not even through yet
with the God of War thing so this cloth
map is just spectacular
but they're not done yet they're not
done yet
in addition to the cloth map of course
you're gonna get the hammer again
the hammer is still in there as well
but then it also gets the seven inch
vinyl record
for the game
which is just awesome that's so awesome
and then the hammer and then I think
that's I think that's it
yeah
so like that all that right there is 260
dollars
then what we saw back here that's two
hundred dollars and then you have
then you have this
no one can defend this
hold on hold on
like even when they get to the end and
they
like there it is
like they they have to put the box in
the picture
because there's not there's not like a
third item
I I man I'd love to get Chandler off the
Record about that one day like maybe
after years from now when he's no longer
working there like okay tell us what you
really thought about having to do that
unboxing
oh man
the hammer doesn't float
the material should absolutely yeah it
should for that price Professor Abbott
you're right
magic Caster 150 Deluxe 80 levitating
snitch 50 better deal
exactly Shadow guided 73 likes 127
people yeah let's get the yeah guys if
you enjoy the stream uh hit that like
button helps more people find uh find
the stream helps YouTube get it out
there to more people always much
appreciated
Hogwarts Legacy at least should have had
an arbor right if they if they would
have included the art book which is the
art book on Amazon in the US right now
it's going for I think 45 I don't know
what the MSRP is going to be if they
know that for sure yet or not but it's
it's currently at 45 dollars
like that if that were part of this
I'd still say it was overpriced but I
would feel I would feel much better
about that than this right here being
300. what they were just banking on is
that people just think this magic wand
is just so incredible
and I mean like people have seen this
stuff man yeah it's cool but the novelty
I feel like well where we're all quickly
no Rob I have not ever opened one of
those but I've I've watched unboxings
for that yeah
did I move my desk no no no I didn't
move anything Mary I just um
there's no spider back here anymore we
took this or the spider was over here
yeah
so the the drawer over here that just
kind of that's not attached to my desk
I can wheel this around anywhere and so
I kind of use it to position some props
and backgrounds when we're doing the
Stream
you have all the Zelda amiibo nice
shadow guided you had one of those you
had the little Harry Potter thing
don't like clutter
what I don't like is the space of
nothingness
wait hold on let me read this again I
agree I don't like clutter what I don't
like oh I I gotcha a space of nothing
it's a blank wall nothing on a top shelf
I gotcha Yeah Yeah in our in our little
uh living room area we have kind of
these built-in shelves
and it would just look so weird if you
had nothing there
I was curious how the unboxing with
Hogwarts Legacy didn't have the regular
game case
oh that don't even get me started on
that game that's another thing I find so
annoying
because I think
wait hold on hold on hold on hold on
I don't know if we know this for sure
yet but but you're right I remember
commenting on this when it happened
is like when he opens everything
there is a space right there why does it
not have
watch this you guys there is a space for
the regular case of the game right there
because this is just the steel book
or steel case
and then you're right at the end
when they do this right here they show
that is so annoying too I hate when
games don't include both the the Metroid
dread collector's edition
which I also I got that one it's on my
top shelf right here
the European version of that included
both the steel case and the regular
cover
and yet
the U.S one didn't
so it could I wonder if this is the same
thing here I wonder if we're going to
have territorial differences like if
some of the territories it actually does
include both and some of them it doesn't
I'm guessing Chandler probably opened
the US one so that doesn't give me a lot
of Hope for hours
Jay Rossi game 80 bucks art book 45
soundtrack score 15 to 20 right
yeah it's frustrating man it's
frustrating because I feel like so many
people
I mean is it the end of the world no but
like it's it's a collector's edition
before we knew what it was where so many
people were ready to drop the money so
many people wanted it because the
possibilities were so I mean I made a
whole video on like 10 things I'd love
to see 10 ideas
and just like the the lowest hanging
fruit possible like a Hogwarts
acceptance letter
I mean come on that would have been such
a
an easy thing to include
Mary said wait what spider yeah yeah we
had one up there for Halloween
should have come up with a light version
and dark version for the collector's
edition yeah that would have been cool
yeah
so I don't know man I
I still have no idea if I'm Gonna Keep
My
my pre-order or not
I wouldn't just outright cancel it
though if I decided I didn't want it I
would definitely make sure that James
I would let James buy it from me
all right let's get some uh background
going here so Mary remind me I'm pretty
sure
aren't you one of the people who is
planning on
um buying the only the switch version
that's what you were looking for of
Hogwarts Legacy we already had a we
talked about the switch already
if it was Wireless that would make the
price worth if the uh
oh wait let me rewind this
are you talking about if the um
even then I don't think so if the you
talk about if the why can I not think of
the word floating magic wand with book
if it didn't have a cord then you think
it would have warranted I I still don't
feel like it would
it just needed it needed one other
like medium-sized item like if you look
at the God of War One they've got like
the big item the big draw which of
course is the hammer for Hogwarts Legacy
they've got the big draw which is the
floating wand but then they needed like
one like a middle tier item
like a cloth map a cloth
painting of Hogwarts
a a um an acceptance letter and then
like a couple of other little items like
soundtrack
for for 300 though it should have
absolutely included the art book
absolutely like that I feel like that is
that's not asking for a lot right there
Kelpie right there's nothing online yeah
street it's like purely for you
I guess if you were streaming it or
something or posting Clips online then
hey look at my 300 Kelpie Road dude
we got Josh in the house as well Josh
how's it going my friend
what do you think about them uh showing
barely any good wizard light stuff ooh I
like that question all the extras have
been dark side and then the house ropes
I've got a couple ideas about that
I got a couple ideas I think part of it
is they know their audience
I've talked about this before on the
channel of like how
anytime I do a video on Dark Arts
something with with evil it does really
well that's just like
that's like the power fantasy that so
many people want for whatever reason is
to run around as an evil uh just casting
evil stuff like crazy that's part of it
the other part of it is I I do think a
lot of the game
is going to be
it's going to be involved with the dark
arts I I think that
will there be some light to balance it
out I hope so I hope they don't miss the
kind of that Whimsical nature of of the
world The Wizarding World I hope they
don't miss out on some of that I don't
think they will
I think they just know that this is the
kind of stuff that
that plays well you know and gets people
talking
but it will be interesting if we see
anything
on that side of things at all now my
other thought about that
retro guy is that I was having this
thought the other day about um
that line that Sebastian uses now I I
know his is just a side quest though but
he makes a comment about how
unforgivable curses shouldn't be
unforgivable if it is saving someone's
life
and I I started to wonders like what if
that is a bigger theme like I know
that's Sebastian's quest line
but what if this whole idea
of the unforgivable curses is something
that is challenged by someone in this
game other than Sebastian like what if
what if that's actually part of the main
story of like
because we know there's no morality
system but we know we're going to be
able to make choices like what if that
is a constant thing that comes up of
where like dude here's a chance where
you using this unforgivable curse could
save this person or it could make this
situation a lot easier it could it could
I don't know it could prevent someone
from getting hurt think of all the
altruistic possibilities you know the
moral dilemmas if you will like what if
a lot of the game was going to be
focused on that
other than and it's not just part of
Sebastian's questline that's
that's kind of my other thought
Nico collector's edition absolutely
absolutely needed the art book
acceptance letter and then yeah then
something like just a little small
something as well something of the
houses
Kelby Road what's the best part right
oh man
I hope it comes with the uh the regular
box as well
I bet it doesn't though dude I bet it
doesn't
like why wouldn't Chandlers have it
maybe they just didn't have that in yet
but then they showed it in the picture
at the end
300 could have had house editions yeah
that's something people always ask for
Jay Rossi on my video where I said I
think it was 10 things I'd love to see
in a Hogwarts Legacy collector's edition
people a bunch of people commented about
that
and I remember thinking that'd be great
but that's just so much money I can't
see them doing that but imagine if they
had like you've seen some of the recent
relaunches of the Harry Potter books
they've done house Editions
so it's the same books but like the
cover is is a house Edition so it's like
the Ravenclaw or the Slytherin or
Hufflepuff or Gryffindor imagine like if
they really wanted to go all out for
fans
that would have been truly amazing
you could even set it up to where it's
like a a pre-order only like you only go
through the Avalanche like the WB site
or something because I get
stuff like that you know they don't know
how many they would need of each house
obviously it's not gonna be perfectly
it's not going to be 25 25 25
that's just not how it's going to shake
out I would guess
so they could have done it all any there
are ways to do it if they really wanted
to
uh let's see I just lost the comment
there let me scroll back up
Josh said is this the month they show
more
no I think it's gonna be December
wait aren't game awards game awards are
December right
all right
yeah game awards are December 8th
yeah and Chandler has said he has been
on record saying we will get gameplay
before the end of the year
before the end of the year
so yeah I we were talking about this
earlier at the start of the stream I
feel like
we might be starting to kind of enter a
slow period now
I hope I'm wrong but we haven't gotten
anything since Halloween like not even a
little like a little drop of an update
we haven't gotten anything
um still no fall ASMR which we're
getting really close to Winter now
so I don't know I don't know
headed out Shadow guided hey thank you
for being here
Josh I hope they'll show more gameplay
game Wars I hope so too that could be
and if like that Sony event seems to not
be happening the one that the rumors
will not go away
it just always keeps coming up 300 I
would have wanted either a niffler
thestral or hippogriff statue included
with the book One the metal case digital
stuff maybe pins with a new yeah I mean
300 is a lot in this economy are you
kidding me
this is a lot to ask of people
the AK work on all beings like would it
work instantly to kill a troll or a
dragon uh Dragons I'm pretty sure their
hide has protection
from a lot of spells so no
in trolls
I it will work on creatures though
because we see it in um
we see Grindelwald do it in the most
recent
fantastic Beast movie
[Music]
yeah Lauren I'm I'm still not I still
don't know what they mean by
every time people explain it to me what
they think it means like okay but still
but still there's no morality system but
you can make choices that will determine
the Witcher wizard you want to be here's
the choices we see the choices on the
cruciologist curse but like does it does
it matter right does it matter
because to me if it matters if it
somehow impacts
the direction of the story in any way
then I feel like that is a
it's not I guess it's not a morality
system that tracks it's not like we're
going to be able to go into our menu
like you could in say uh
I'm pretty sure Mass Effect had this
where you could like see
how how close you were Paragon or
Renegade you know I don't think it's
going to be like that
as long as it will have some impact on
the story though I'm fine with that
you don't think dark arts is a is a big
main story because they're optional
spells well
we know that
prusio is optional
yeah I think they'll all be optional I
do
but I still think even if the I I think
maybe not using them as a big part but
the dark arts themselves of like
you're either resisting or you're
tempted by them
I mean you're either you have to if
you're tempted you have to resist right
or you give in
so I think that will be a big theme yeah
and in the ancient magic good point J
Ross yeah the ancient magic is the one
that's like
that opens up the possibilities for so
many so much flexibility there there's
so many different things they could do
in terms of that because it's it's
something we've not really seen a lot of
specifics on before
do do
ASMR should be on the 18th like the
others oh
wait were both of them posted on the
same day
okay May 18th
and then a hot summer day
oh my gosh
no profile name
was it right under our noses this whole
time
was it right under our noses this whole
time
dude maybe it's gonna be just like the
other two
November 18th
oh that's it
what is no hold on I'm gonna see what
day of the week each of these were
Okay so
oh it just so October 18th fell on a
Tuesday that was perfect
September 18th was on a Saturday a
Sunday wait did they release it on a
Sunday
oh no it was August 18th yeah yeah two
months
so August 18th was a Thursday okay so
for the August one they released it on a
Thursday the 18th
for October it was Tuesday the 18th
so for us for this month the 18th is on
a Friday
and you know they're not going to
release it
maybe they release it the week of
Thanksgiving
I know for those of you in the UK you
don't have that holiday but it's a
pretty big holiday for us here in the
U.S so
I can't and then Black Friday they're
not gonna do anything on Black Friday
the day after Thanksgiving that's a
really big shopping day
I don't see them doing anything that
whole week probably unless they have
like some sort of special
nah I don't even think they would do a
Thanksgiving post because they have a
global audience and that's not a global
holiday so
so yeah I feel like any time between now
and the 18th
you could be exactly right
now December 18th though is on a Sunday
January 18th is on a Wednesday
we gotta get a winter ASMR in there too
maybe they just released that one on
Christmas though
why why planning a Sony showcase When
the Game Awards in December
I mean like Sony usually like they
usually like to do their own like have
at least one of their own big shows at
least once a year
but I don't know maybe they're just
waiting maybe they're just decided not
to do it this year
or like you said maybe they're just like
hey let's have a really big presence to
Game Awards
that's that's possible too
okay sorry I'm I'm way behind on
comments guys my apologies I'm gonna
have to scroll scroll through some of
these
okay all right now I am caught
now I'm caught up
November is a Friday
wait did I look at this wrong
oh I did say Thursday didn't I yeah
November 18th is a Friday
which they could do that
yeah I feel like any time between today
well obviously not today tomorrow
November 9th all the way through
November 18th I feel like those are the
most likely times
for the ASMR
yo house in the house yet again sorry
I'm late with the dollar 99 Super Chat
house thank you so much for your
continued support of the channel very
much appreciate that Super Chat glad
you're here and remember house a wizard
is never late
wizard is never late house nor is he
early
white wolf Sony isn't isn't having a
show because they will reveal all their
exclusive content which would kill them
trying to stop the Activision do oh gosh
yeah don't even get me started on that
hole
oh geez the whole Activision thing going
on
but to be fair like Sony's exclusives
are
I mean mostly from Studios they have
owned and built up and not just went out
and bought
after they've grown to the size of uh
Activision so it's a little bit
of a different story but yeah they have
they have been uh
being kind of careful what they're
saying lately
oh I did see that Zach Zachary Leslie
Phillips the man that did the voice for
the Sorting Hat has died R.I.P yeah very
sad it's gonna be
man
is this uh
I feel like that older generation like
the older generation of the Harry Potter
cast
man it's it's crazy how many of them
have already passed
now we figured it out big brain right
Dishonored had a morality skill that had
different endings you could see where
you were at on the scale at the end of
the chapter I don't remember if he could
Deering it yeah I mean that's what I'm
like I'm so confused when they say no
morality system well okay but there's so
many ways you could still go about that
another Super Chat just came in Odin
killer hey I didn't even know we were
here my friend welcome
sent a 4.99 Super Chat a retro random
but with the inferior and troll
couldn't it be more that inferior are
seen as an enemy to All Creatures it's
been bothering me for a bit oh yeah yeah
so
Odin killer is referring to in one of my
latest video well I think we may have
even talked about it on a live stream
before too
so I'm pretty sure it's in the
Sebastian's Dark Legacy trailer
foreign
so if we go toward the end of the oh oh
my gosh that is creepy you guys I went
right to it
I don't know if that shows you how many
times I've watched this or what
so there's a scene in this where
we pretty clearly see
oh that scene that shot right there is
so gorgeous
so obviously in theory heavily involved
with this trailer but right here look at
that one swipe not one
but two I mean look at that dude he is
so focused on taking out that in Fury
right there
so I've been trying to speculate why
would the troll
why is the troll going crazy on the
inferior
right there one swing so it'd be one
thing if it was just the first swing
right like you know troll just going
crazy there's a lot of stuff in their
way
they don't care they're just swinging at
whatever right but then he goes for that
second swing like very deliberately
and now that we've learned that imperio
is in the game and that we can cast an
imperial I was speculating on this even
before we knew about imperio but my
thought is
what if we have the troll in Period
in Period under the imperious curse
right here
now the we the kind of weird thing about
it though
is he does have
let's see right
right here we can see
he's got he's got the red eyes for sure
right there you can see them right there
you can see them
and so so far the red eyes
have been the way that we see the
corruption
so we know that some creatures are under
this corruption we see it earlier with
the uh with the goblins with the big
Goblin that are or not the big Goblin
the big troll that bursts out of uh in
the hogsmeade area we see it there and
we see it in some of the Goblins too
this one looks a little bit different so
maybe this is a maybe this is a signal
that they're under the imperious curse
so that's one possibility another
possibility is that
which you want to get you talk about
dark we were I think it may have even
been Chad who suggested this a few
streams ago is like what if
our wizard is the one who
created the inferior
and so the troll
we're using the inferior to try and
battle the troll
either way it's they're both crazy right
both crazy
but then to the question here
Odin killer saying couldn't it be more
that the inferior are seen as an enemy
to All Creatures
I mean maybe
but I feel like the in theory we were
talking about this last time we were
trying to figure out
like once they're created are they kind
of just
uncontrollable even for the even for the
wizard controlling them
I don't think so I feel like the wizard
controlling them would have some control
over it
otherwise what would be the point right
unless you just like like the situation
with Voldemort you just strictly want
them to be used to guard something
which we didn't see Voldemort did not
use any in theory in the Battle of
Hogwarts right but he did use like even
Dementors he was using in the Battle of
Hogwarts all other kinds of creatures
so yeah I mean that that could be a
possibility yeah
I still prefer I still prefer to think
it's
I still prefer to think it's under the
imperious curse which we know is a
possibility now Imperial has been
confirmed and they've even said that
we can cast imperio and they talked
about how
um how long the
the target will
or they didn't talk about how long but
they talked about how the target will
fight for you they get a buff so they
they don't take as much damage from
other enemies but they take more damage
from you
so I still hope I hope it ends up being
something like that instead of just ads
just like a crazy battle and the troll
is just going crazy the troll doesn't
care what's around it he's just swinging
at anything
that may be the most likely but I think
the others are a little bit more fun
most things stop on Saturday and Sunday
in the UK like it's the end of uh every
work week yeah yeah it's it's
kind of I mean it's the same here too
most I mean like traditional businesses
are
nine to five Monday through Friday like
that's what we call like banking hours
but now there are so many other types of
businesses you know where they're
they're open earlier they're open later
and then you have
um I mean like a lot of stores now are
open on weekends if you're working in
the restaurant business or if you're in
the hospitals if you're in healthcare
you're going to be working weekends
but to your point yeah like our our work
week is is Monday through Friday is how
people think of it and then you know
like there's no school on the weekends
as well so things do slow down a bit
a bit for us as well
[Music]
Gilly weed Gilly would be awesome yeah
yeah the waters the water's still a big
question right we still don't really
know
we don't really know I kind of go back
and forth on it
the game already seems so big to me that
I almost feel like it would be too much
not not too much for me I would love it
but I feel like it may have been too
much for them to attempt
foreign
what is Noob saying hold on
everybody's agreeing with Noob here
oh about poppy maybe the creatures
aren't as big a deal there's a bad guy
who's mean to the creatures like oh yeah
I mean the creatures are definitely
being a lot of them are being held
captive
a lot of them are being held captive
Nico do I still have yeah I still have
that wand yeah
that's one of my uh that's one of the
coolest gifts anybody's ever given me
one of my friends I showed it off on a
video
it's an old video but you guys can still
find it on the channel one of my friends
made a custom wand for me his last name
is strong
and so instead of it being like
ollivanders or something he had a little
label on there that was that was
Strong's wands
and uh he knows I'm a big PlayStation
fan so like the at the base of my wand
he carved them himself and at the base
of the wand he has like the PlayStation
symbols carved into it super cool
all these theories make you happy and
excited equally stressed
I agree Mary if it's one of those I
think it's I think it's definitely leans
more toward the Imperial side of things
but I do think
I don't know what I think the most
likely is probably just random fighting
I'll say I'll say 50 chance that it's
just random fighting 40 chance that it's
the troll under imperio 10 chance that
we're controlling the inferior
that's what I think
goblins are using magic to control
creatures for an army or something
that's possible yeah we don't know much
about the corruption yet I
I'm hoping that there's more to the
story than just like oh it's a goblin
Rebellion
I mean because as we know from the books
I mean the goblins
they kind of the Wizards didn't treat
them the best
and the Goblins didn't there was wrong
on both sides is what we know
and the other thing about goblins is
like
we don't really have a good real world
comparison for that
because in some ways they're they're
almost they're very animalistic in some
ways
like they're they're creatures but then
they also have this high intelligence
so they they absolutely deserve they
need to have some rights in in The
Wizarding World but then there's also
like for protection of the human
population
it's just it's a really it's a really
tricky one
but I I hope that the game explores a
little bit more of the other side which
I have confidence that it that it will
because of that scene with us talking
with that Goblin in the hog's head
a different Goblin so not ran Rock we're
talking with another Goblin in the hog's
head
so I think there's gonna be two sides to
I mean there's definitely going to be
more Nuance to the story than just oh
Goblin's bad
hahaha
but it could I mean the Goblins could
absolutely Rand Rock could be the main
one behind it he really could
but we know what we know for sure about
in theory is that there has to be a dark
witch or wizard behind that
that has to be a dark Witcher wizard
oh my gosh poppy created the inferior
could you imagine
could you imagine
hey thanks for linking that video uh
Nico
prefix bath must be pretty deep to have
a diving board
indeed
hey feathers didn't realize you were
here welcome how's it going how long has
the game been in development do you
think if it's been like five plus six
years more than likely I will be
swimming
well let's see when was the leak was it
at 28
teen was that when we got the first leak
so we know it had been in development
before then I mean before the the leak
for sure
no the leak hold on the leak
yeah I think the leak was 2018.
poppy grindelwald's granddaughter what
if the ancient magic protects us
underwater of any Elemental situation
I'd love it if there were puzzles
Moon Lily I would love that I don't
think I would love the ancient sea
they gotta be careful with this ancient
magic business because I I kind of joke
around that anything that they can't
explain within the normal lore they can
just be like oh well you know ancient
magic it'll take care of that yeah just
just some little ancient Magic on it
it's good little ancient magic powers
that's it so I hope they can't overuse
that they got to be careful with that
and I think they will
but I do think we'll see some things
that's like oh that's kind of a
curveball there for what the ancient
magic can do but yeah I don't think I
would enjoy it too much if it was
ancient magic can make you breathe
underwater I'd rather them just be like
you know you already got the room of
requirement you already have all these
plants that we're growing you already
have all these potions were Brewing just
do Gilly weed man like just have Gilly
weed in there
and then have that as a consumable that
we have to use before we dive
what if the Ravenclaw companion is a
prefect and we get access to the
bathroom through there oh yo
I like that idea
yeah there won't be a Marauders map
I saw a question about that yeah it
wouldn't have been uh created yet
2018 okay yeah I was thinking it was
2018.
D ran extra long tonight ah gotcha
gotcha
Poppy's evil turns people into animals
oh
we know she likes animals more than
humans
we know that
we know that
oh yeah I don't I hope no time Turners
man
I hope for No Time Turners could help us
get a dragon though because they also
have ancient magic now see like that I'm
fine with yes
yes like the dragons are a very powerful
wouldn't be surprising at all if the
dragon the main dragon that hybridian
black that we keep seeing I know James
has talked about this a lot but like the
you see the blue on the like the chest
of that dragon
and it's that same kind of tint of blue
the same tint of blue you see in the
background right now
the ancient magic is all around us guys
it's all around
no but the uh it looks an awful lot like
the same ancient magic that we see like
with the lightning
do dead be insane if it if it connects
to the dragon somehow
that'd be so cool why am I yawning oh
I don't know why I'm yawning it's only
10 24 I should be good for another
couple of hours
DND on weekdays sounds hard to manage
but I'm jealous
oh wait hold on what do you guys
somebody said something about Port key
oh could have potentially been around
when portkey was formed yeah yeah
2017 yeah it wouldn't shock me at all if
it was in 2017 because clearly by 2018
they had they had quite a bit to show
so I would I mean
you think about that leaked trailer
there was a I mean that was
that looked like the game was you know a
year or two away honestly
so maybe it was in development even more
back further than that you know what
Troy might have talked about this in his
interview with podcast now
I can't remember for sure
but I feel like 17 I feel like 2017
minimum yeah since then
and yeah to your point feathers they
could have even started it before then
because WB
I'm still not totally clear how the
whole like labeling thing works because
WB is also the publisher but portkey
games is a publisher just for like
Wizarding World stuff
so it's like
they say it's being published by Warner
Brothers under the port key games label
is what they say but they're both their
names are going to be in the Box
so
Philip I know the Ravenclaw companion
do you Phillip
we could have it be that we can't swim
until we get access to gillyweed or cast
the bubble head charm yeah that'd be
cool
or you can swim but like you can't oh
that'd be even better you know how like
some games like they'll let you go down
but then you've got your your breath
meter so you have to come back up
oh so you could like start to see some
things that like oh I want to explore
that but I can't yet
personally I would rather use what I
learned in class but there's so much
Unknown about the ancient Magic
agreed yeah
oh you think it's the you think it's the
Ravenclaw in the second trailer
it could be yeah
and we we actually see we see a couple
of ravenclaws actually
in the trailers
speculating about Dev time because
that's an indication of the scope of the
game true true
emphasis on creatures oh yeah I think
I think you're spot on with that Rossi I
think you're the first person I heard
that from a couple streams back
we taught we've talked a lot about the
magical creatures and how important
they're going to be but then Jay Rossi
brought up
we know that Sebastian's twin sister and
suffers from a debilitating curse
a lot of people are thinking maledictus
and there's so this huge emphasis on
creatures and taking care of creatures
oh
could totally be a thing where
as that storyline progresses they have
to prepare for how they're gonna take
care of her once she fully
transforms into into the uh the magical
being
magical creature
Noob Noob there you go guys you heard it
here first Noob is actually the
Ravenclaw companion
confirmed
oh goodness would be funny if we could
pull some Call of Duty mission where you
swim underwater break
ing dude oh one thing we haven't talked
about here
oh my gosh I covered this in my
hold on I'm pretty sure I posted
wait a minute did I do uh
oh yeah I did a short a YouTube short on
this
so if you don't watch YouTube shorts you
might have missed this it was just such
a quick thing
so when they revealed the artem making
of Hogwarts Legacy did you guys see this
giant squid basically confirmed
hold on I'm gonna pull up a better I'm
gonna pull up a picture for you all
I'm almost positive we didn't talk about
this on stream maybe we did I don't know
it's been so long but we missed that
week and I feel like we uh
I feel like I'm even further back
all right so this is the cover of the
art book glorious by the way just
glorious
I love like just the the style of this
art so not like imagine if they had put
oh
just put that in the collection Edition
is it too late
is it too late
and then not I mean not a lot of
craziness here we've obviously already
seen Hogwarts many many many many many
times
but then if you zoom in they gave us
just a little tease right here
a little tease
because we see all these tentacles over
here
and then a tentacle over here giant
squid ladies and gentlemen there you go
now see here's the thing it would have
to be a different giant squid it
couldn't be the giant squid from Harry
Potter's time at Hogwarts
be it'd be like the great grandmother of
the the giant squid in Harry Potter I
don't mean I don't know how long did
magical giant squid live maybe it's an
enchanted giant squid that just it's
part of the school the founders created
it and put it there
dude imagine if there's like oh my gosh
I hesitate to even say this because this
is just like
oh man this is just like completely just
bizarre speculation let it be known I'm
not making any kind of theories or any
I'm just saying complete bizarre
speculation we're all here chatting
we're just here having fun that's all
this is guys
we we know from that leaked Autodesk
those file names it's possible there
might be some kind of battle at Hogwarts
at some point in this game
and we know that magical creatures are
going to be heavily involved dude what
if they like what if they're trying to
subdue the giant squid and the giant
squid is just not having it it's just
not having it
so what if we get a scene where we
we have to like help the giant squid we
have to free the giant squid an
underwater mission to free the giant
squid you guys oh
come on Avalanche make it happen make
our wildest fan hopes come true
I'm just I mean just just think about
these tentacles like you're you're
fighting over here on the grounds and
then just out of nowhere a a tentacle
just knocks some of the dark Wizards out
of your way
giant squid Legacy
the great grand
yeah there's a colony of giant squids
living exactly
how scary that would be no one whoever
we do know that the giant squid is most
likely it's friendly though because it
rescued I think it was was it Colin
creevy that the giant squid rescued
still wild and it defends a puzzle
dungeon underwater yeah stuff like that
I think would be so fun
but it's to the point I mean the giant
squid
it's it's got to be somewhat friendly
though gotta be somewhat friendly
all right let's go back to the uh
somebody was uh Philip I think it was
was it Philip here
yo L went in the house Elwyn welcome to
the Stream
welcome to the stream Elwyn gifting out
five
tier one memberships
Owen thank you so much for always
showing the love and support to the
channel and look at that Lauren D has
been here almost the whole
entire stream
Lauren got one of those gifted
memberships
as did DJ Darth Starkiller
Jenny has been here for a while as well
Carlos with a gifted and then Luke with
a gifted
by the way any of you who just got one
of those gifteds you actually can
use all the little emotes
or Emoji whatever you call it you can
use all the little Emoji now
and you unlock uh you also get
discounted but let me see if I can pull
this up
I go to your my channel Community I have
to be careful here because I don't want
to show
why am I not logged in
why can I not okay yeah I'm not gonna
hit it right here because there's a
special code here for channel members
uh you get discounted merch if you're a
channel member you also get like a
special like I post some things here to
get feedback sometimes from Members Only
so like if you ever see these that have
like Members Only
and then like when we uh unveiled our
new Emoji I asked I usually ask the
members for feedback so you get access
to all that you get access to the Emoji
so make sure you think Elwyn
for gifting out those those memberships
there so I'm not gonna hit this right
here but if you go to my if you go to
the main uh Channel page here and then
you go to community right here and then
you or no I'm sorry
if you go to membership right here not
community and then you click that little
drop down right there show perks info it
will show you the code for the merge
discount and all the other things that
you get
which I've been thinking about guys I've
been trying to come up with
I don't want to tease too much yet I
don't want to tease too much but I've
been trying to come up with some other
a lot actually not some a lot of other
perks to where we can maybe even add
another tier or two
but I'm not I'm not going to add more
tears until I can actually deliver
something that you guys would find
worthwhile so
I don't want to just add it to add it
you know
now I got to scroll back up and see what
Elwyn said here it looked like some big
news
okay there's all the gifteds
and then uh let's see what did Elwyn say
here
today was my final Tuesday dog training
class I'm here every Tuesday now yo
let's go for a second I read that I
thought you said it was your final dog
training class ever
I'm just gonna say what what do you mean
what happened are you changing careers
no that's awesome Elwyn congrats yeah we
didn't get to go uh we didn't get to do
the live stream last week so appreciate
you all being here and and showing back
up even though we we took a week off
there
Ellen very important what are your
thoughts on poppy Sweeting
is Poppy the most evil character in
Hogwarts Legacy
I mean we do have that that creepy shot
you know
we do have that very creepy shot of her
I feel like poppy will be slaying people
without Mercy Noob always Noob is like
the the jokester of of our group here
Noob always always cracking the jokes
they say giant squids only live like
five years that's
Jordan that's true for like real world
giant squids
but I also think real world giant squids
they're they're uh salt water only
the HP lexicon believe it or not
I'm almost positive they have a an entry
on this
notes okay so here they go giant squids
are not magical creatures curious isn't
it that Rowling chose to put this
particular non-magical creature at
Hogwarts of all places on the other hand
this particular giant squid certainly
doesn't act like a normal one so it
would certainly seem to be at least
somewhat magical I agree with that note
right there
I think it's somewhat magical because
I'm pretty sure giant squids are only
yeah here you go while the giant squid
is a deep saltwater creature at least
one giant squid lives in the freshwater
lake near Hogwarts Castle and seems to
be more or less friendly toward the
inhabitants
this was something on Pottermore
which makes me think like the tapping on
the glass it has to be the giant squid
it has to be the giant squid I meant to
talk about this I I came across this
doing some research for something else
and I meant to make a tweet or a post or
something about this but I mean does
this not just like
I can almost guarantee you the people at
Avalanche research in the game
extensively looked at this website the
HP lexicon along with the HP Wiki along
with Pottermore they probably looked at
all this stuff extensively I mean this
was on Pottermore right here our common
room lies behind a concealed uh entrance
down in the dungeons yep we know that as
you'll see its Windows look out into the
depths of the Hogwarts Lake yep we know
that we often see the giant squid
swooshing by and sometimes more
interesting creatures
so dude
tap in the glass giant squid let's go
let's go
you just said all that Alicia nice
Ellen won't know how she feels about
poppy until she sees how poppy treats
puppies there we go I mean now that you
want to talk about a Twist if poppy was
in any way harmful to magical creatures
that would be the biggest Twist of all
that would be a huge twist I think
Poppy's gonna be like
if poppy does anything remotely evil
it's going to be toward humans not
toward magical creatures
for sure
magical by associated with Hogwarts
could be yeah maybe it has a deep
connection to the ancient Magic
yo Nico with the four months of being a
channel member here make sure to smash
the like button on Retro's God of War
videos ahead of tomorrow's leads hey
thank you so much Nico yeah we've been
doing uh I had a couple I've had a
couple God of War videos but
they haven't gotten picked up too well
it's just like the way YouTube works man
it'll just take time
because I used to only cover I covered
Animal Crossing for a while and those
videos didn't do anything and then I
made a lot of animal crossing videos and
then YouTube was like oh
okay let's promote these and so then
they started getting lots of views but
by that point I'd already started making
Hogwarts Legacy videos
and so then I started making more
Hogwarts Legacy videos and then
YouTube's like hey let's push this out a
little more and so then when I do
anything that's not Hogwarts Legacy
right now YouTube's like
hmm what is this no no we're just not
nobody's gonna click on this so
no but basically what happens is it
shows it to the Hogwarts audience and if
you guys aren't interested in it so be
it you know that's fine you're here for
Hogwarts Legacy I get it
um but then like the click-through rate
it tells YouTube like oh this is not the
right audience and so then it just takes
a lot longer for that video to get
to get picked up but yeah there's I
really want to do a God of War video on
I've recorded footage for like the first
the whole first hour of that game I feel
like it's so good at rebooting that
entire franchise
and it it completely sets the tone so
well
but Nico thank you so much for
continuing to be a channel member here
also a moderator here in the house uh
Big Sky Ride I'm gonna start with
Gryffindor
a Gryffindor good slash Paragon whatever
you want to call it play through
foreign
casts AK on a magical creature
hold on hold on hold on let me think
let me think let me think of something
that I could legitimately do
that would be funny
if poppy Cass AKA on a magical creature
in Hogwarts Legacy
I will
hold on before I say this I want to see
something here
I already bought
every flavor beans
where can I buy these things
oh my goodness they're actually on
Amazon
I'm tempted to say I will eat a whole
pack of these on a stream
but I want to know how many are in here
I wonder how many are I need to see
where James gets his this does not look
like the same
same pack that James has
48 pack 48 packs in a box oh my goodness
I can't find it maybe you guys know
but yeah I don't think there's any way
I don't think there's any way Poppy's
gonna cast AK on a magical creature
uh Professor bins Philip yeah yeah
Professor bins actually it was your
comment Philip that's why I pulled up
the trailer I wanted to uh
so they're actually
oh no wait it's the first hold on in the
first Hogwarts Legacy trailer
we're talking about
possible Ravenclaw companions
there's actually two
in this trailer
there's one I'm pretty sure this
character right here
right there
that character's a Ravenclaw
that's a possibility
and then also when our I think this is
just another version of the main
character though right here
this other one
wait I feel like I've missed it
oh yeah it's right here in this scene
right after this
this character right there
I don't think that's a
I mean it could be
either one of those could could be the
Ravenclaw companion I guess
and then the other one that we see is
right
here
so which one were you talking about
Philip
we're talking about the first one that
we see there
or the second one we see here fighting
the troll
get the birdie Bots keepsake
the second trailer okay all right all
right let's go to the second trailer so
that one is the state of play
this one's the long one
so what what scene are you thinking here
in this one
for the Ravenclaw companion
when your chat just goes totally off the
rails on Poppy
I don't think she's evil I really don't
but I do think because of the the way
the fans have reacted I think there's
going to be
some like fun little Easter egg in there
I do think we could see her like taking
out some poachers though no doubt
no doubt I think we could see her aking
some poachers
she gets mad enough
I could definitely see that
come on Phillip which one you thinking
here
this trailer's too long for me to skim
through
shrewd monkey welcome my friend
puppy has no Patronus because she has no
happy memories just constantly gets you
by malice oh my goodness
her happy memory is oh my gosh
using AK on someone else
I mean dude you guys know
Umbridge can cast a Patronus right
umbers can cast Patronus so it's not
just
happy memories for some people
are not happy for all of us that's for
sure
that's for sure
Philip where are you oh you're talking
about wait and the dark arts hold on
Philip might be meaning the dark arts
the dark arts wasn't the second trailer
but
all right come on Phillip come on Philip
you gotta give me more to work with here
dark Hearts trailer Hogwarts Legacy
I don't if it's the student that we see
I don't think that's the student because
that that looks like another Slytherin
like right there
that's so hard to tell but I think
that's a Slytherin
and then the one that we see standing by
the door I also think is a Slytherin
trailer is so dark
right there maybe that one
I think we only see a slytherins
maybe that is that does kind of look
that kind of looks blue right there
but it could just as easily be green
just the lighting
it would be kind of cool though if after
they finally revealed the Ravenclaw
campaign and if we're like oh the
Ravenclaw companion was in the first
trailer all along
foreign
oh man
I thought you were just joking about
that Tom are you being for real
go to the Long Trailer Professor
profotions is walking in and look at
poppy in the background
you talking about the state of play
because he appears in both of them
I was just watching this the other day
for for a video I was
I was having to watch this scene again
the scene with him is always so quick in
this one I can never find it in the uh
when I'm just skimming I can hardly ever
find it oh there he was right
come on catch up YouTube
oh my gosh
no she's not giving him a death stare
dude she's she's like breaking the
fourth wall though right
it's she's staring right into our very
Souls
she's staring into our souls right there
all right let me do let me do this if I
uh
let's see I should be able to save this
as a screenshot
all right
ah
Poppy's a werewolf
I don't think Poppy's a werewolf
although although
I kid
all right so let's let's crop this and
then I'm gonna zoom in here
yeah that's what that's what every this
is what you guys look like to me over
here
got my OBS this is where I can see all
the recent events so like memberships
and everything
over here on the left is the the chat
box
all right so I'm gonna do this save
all right now we should be able to
oh there we go
no she looks like
she looks very sweet right there
why is she staring right at the camera
that is that's a little bit that's a
little bit creepy I'll give you that
foreign
creeping
so shocked when poppy turns
when she turns out to be exactly what
they told us all along
poppy Sweeting
Big Sky Ride uh for sure we'll see a
Weasley I think we will see a professor
Weasley but it's not
the red-headed Professor it's not the
herbology professor
foreign
I think there'll be at least one student
Weasley as well
probably the one that we see with red
hair that's a Gryffindor
would be my guess
she looks dead inside
oh my goodness
pure evil says gay but we probably won't
because it's
played out for them to be good after all
poppy is a flavor right Poppy and
Sweeting
think Remus he looked normal
Remus wasn't like an evil psychopath
like you guys are
flowers wither
dude
need to know more about the herbology
professor
well we think we think her name excuse
me we think her name is Helen
thistlewood
which I think makes sense
Philip not joking around
I don't know what you're talking about
Philip
oh okay wait I see your comment back
here now the one they're both casting
the spell together in the dark arts
classroom
what
that's this trailer
that's this trailer
right
we just passed it
I mean look we do see
now talk about you guys can't say
anything about the background because
they the background characters were
rough they they were kind of rough
looking here
the the models on these are looking
looking a little off they they still had
some work to do like
you think in that character right there
the one with the glasses
the guy with the glasses okay yeah yeah
it's possible yeah it's definitely
possible now that looks like the guy
he's not a Ravenclaw though it looks
like he's got the uh is that
I think we see just a glimpse of gold
let me go back here
oh yeah okay so
that does look similar to the character
but he's Hufflepuff right there
yeah right there
Harry's great Granddad great great
granddad
I know I've seen that theory going
around too
I feel like that the longer that time
passes we just start
we just start picking random stuff to uh
to just like go all in with ethereon
now who are we dueling right there is it
is it Sebastian
yeah it's Sebastian that we're
that we're dueling
Romeo do you think the game will live up
to the hype
it's still hard to say
I think given what we've seen I think
they they will knock it out of the park
with the exploration
with the discovery all that I'm feeling
very confident about I feel like they
will meet the expectations on what I
don't know and because we just haven't
seen it we don't we can't say for sure
is the is the gameplay and like how how
the game will run
like is the game actually fun to play I
have no doubt the game will be fun to
explore no doubt I feel like it will
definitely live up to the expectations
there
but in terms of the actual game like
like playing it as a game like going
through and doing the quests it's just
hard to say it's really hard to say
until we see a little bit more
and we know we got to know how it runs
right like how well is this thing gonna
run is it gonna be filled with bugs and
glitches when it launches hopefully not
hopefully that's why you know they
delayed it to take care of all that now
here's the shot of the diving board we
were trying to earlier you all were
talking about the diving board or the uh
this bathroom must have a deep
pool here for them to have a diving
board I mean yeah look at that these
stairs that let's see that's one two or
hold on if we start counting with that
one two three four five six seven eight
nine at least 10 stairs right there
to get in to get into that uh pool
hope they also add in little things like
sitting in the Great Hall eating meals a
lot of conversations between students
yeah to make it to make the world feel
more alive for sure yeah I hope so too
could there be like a swimming tunnel in
that pool that'd be fun
well I mean they could that would kind
of break that would be different from
the can that we know because Harry
didn't comment on any sort of hidden
hidden passage there but
it's D it looks deep enough for sure
it looks deep enough
they do say we will meet students in
Social Gathering areas yeah
opinion on on quidditch not being
playable uh oh see we were talking about
the corruption earlier
like
that red looks very similar to the red
of the troll
dude look at this though like look at
this like
so cool right there
let's watch it again in real time like
watch this one right here watch what he
what he does
oh what an attack man
I'm gonna slow it down
he has this ax
that he swings
but then there's like oh
there's like a demon Goblin that emerges
and see all of those goblins have the
red eyes
and these goblins have the red eyes so
they're under look at that there's
another one oh dude they lunge with that
too
but to your question about um the uh
the Quidditch I have a video on it I'm
not I'm not too upset about it
I think it's a game that's already so
big and for something that would really
be nothing but a side a side mission
they would have had to devote so much
time to making that to making it happen
and make it actually be fun
or they they could have made it like a
very cheap throwaway minigame but
I don't think people would have been
happy with that either so
it's just a matter of managing resources
I think and if they're like if you have
to cut something I'd much rather them
cut quidditch than like making sure it's
a it's a really good story or making
sure the spell casting system works
really well
Ravenclaw Terrell says good night all
leaving work headed back home hope I'm
able to catch most of y'all at Wizarding
Wednesday that's right I think James is
a
as far as I know James is doing a stream
tomorrow night
one hour till God of War oh man I'm not
gonna be playing at midnight sadly
sadly
but it is getting pretty late here guys
so I think we're gonna go ahead and wrap
it up here for the evening uh thank you
all so much for hanging out man it's
it's been
I missed uh I I was I definitely needed
the break last week I needed to to catch
up to rest up but I have I came back
rejuvenated energized and we'll kind of
see man what happens with Hogwarts
Legacy over the next couple of days
slash weeks leading up to the
Thanksgiving holiday in the U.S and then
into December
because man I'm telling you guys like I
know it's quiet right now but enjoy this
last little bit because I feel like this
is the this is the Calm before the storm
this is the Calm before the storm it is
it is going to pick up and once once
January gets here you guys
unless there's another
the d word that we're not going to say
again unless there's another one of
those
I mean early January guys we could start
seeing
preview copies go out
that's when we can start seeing preview
copies go out
and we're in mid-november of well not
quite mid-november yet but I mean we're
we're weak into November at this point
January will be here before you know it
and that's when you're gonna start
getting
all kinds of of coverage of this game
I don't know about everybody else but I
know you guys know the Hogwarts Legacy
creators who are going to be
pumping out the content for this game
and as soon as uh if we get early copies
I hope we do
then it's it's gonna make the content
even better and I don't know if it'll
make it even better but it'll make it
come out much faster I can guarantee
that
so
yeah I think that's gonna be it make
sure you guys check out the Discord if
you're new here tonight we had a lot of
gifted members again tonight so welcome
to all of those those of you who got
gifted memberships new subscribers as
well uh I don't know what our our video
is going to be yet this week I was kind
of waiting I hadn't recorded anything
yet I was waiting to see if we were
gonna get any um any posts from
Avalanche this week maybe the ASMR but
so far it's uh you know it's only
Tuesday so we still got three days left
in the week so we'll see what tomorrow
holds
but yeah thank you all so much for being
here
hope you all have a wonderful rest of
your evening and I will talk to you
again soon
foreign
foreign